I had, there's a new, I don't actually remember the name of the place, but there's a Montreal bagel place that just opened in Toronto. And they had these very small, the holes were very large in them. I was a bit confused on why there was not more bagel. And I gotta be honest, I was like, I took a bite and was my first thought was this is not as good as the bagels I had in New York. Oh, you heard it here first. I swear I did not pay Connor anything for that. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 73, recorded on April 14th, 2022. My name is Connor.
I had, there's a new, I don't actually remember the name of the place, but there's a Montreal bagel place that just opened in Toronto. And they had these very small, the holes were very large in them. I was a bit confused on why there was not more bagel. And I gotta be honest, I was like, I took a bite and was my first thought was this is not as good as the bagels I had in New York. Oh, you heard it here first. I swear I did not pay Connor anything for that. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 73, recorded on April 14th, 2022. My name is Connor.|||我有家新开的，其实我记不清那地方叫什么了，不过有一家蒙特利尔贝果店刚在多伦多开业。他们的贝果非常小，中间的洞很大。我有点困惑为什么贝果肉这么少。说实话，我咬了一口，当时的第一想法是这不如我在纽约吃的贝果。哦，你们在这里头条听到这个。我发誓我可没为此给康纳一分钱。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 73 期，录制于 2022 年 4 月 14 日。我是康纳。
And today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Jason Walter and Patrice Roy on the upcoming CPP North conference in Toronto, Canada, as well as bagels and so much more. Dear listener, this is Connor from the editing bay. And I just quickly wanted to let you know that there were a plethora of issues, audio issues, issues of Bryce hopping around from topic to topic. So one, the audio at about the 40% mark is going to get slightly worse due to the fact that we had to switch to the audio from the Zoom recording. And also chopping this episode up is probably the hardest episode I've had to edit so far. So we're going to be jumping around. This episode is going to be primarily focusing on CPP North and related topics. And we'll have a second part to this episode that's going to focus on the other tangential topics that we talked about.
And today with my co-host Bryce, we interview Jason Walter and Patrice Roy on the upcoming CPP North conference in Toronto, Canada, as well as bagels and so much more. Dear listener, this is Connor from the editing bay. And I just quickly wanted to let you know that there were a plethora of issues, audio issues, issues of Bryce hopping around from topic to topic. So one, the audio at about the 40% mark is going to get slightly worse due to the fact that we had to switch to the audio from the Zoom recording. And also chopping this episode up is probably the hardest episode I've had to edit so far. So we're going to be jumping around. This episode is going to be primarily focusing on CPP North and related topics. And we'll have a second part to this episode that's going to focus on the other tangential topics that we talked about.|||今天我和共同主持布莱斯一起采访了杰森·沃尔特和帕特里斯·罗伊，谈论即将于加拿大多伦多举办的 CPP North 会议，还有贝果以及更多内容。亲爱的听众朋友，我是来自剪辑室的康纳。我只想简单告诉大家，这里有大量的问题，音频问题，还有布莱斯跳跃于各个话题之间的问题。所以第一，音频在大约 40% 的进度时会稍微变差一点，因为我们不得不切换到 Zoom 录音的音频。而且剪辑这一集可能是我迄今为止剪过最难的一集。所以我们会跳来跳去。本集将主要关注 CPP North 及相关话题。我们还会有本集的第二部分，专注于我们讨论的其他离题话题。
So strap in, enjoy. And in two weeks' time, hopefully we'll be back to crystal clear audio for the duration of the full podcast. All right. Well, maybe we should just go ahead and get started. I mean, this will be the second time out of three times that we've had two guests on where one of the guests did not show up. So we got a really bad track record. We're at a 67% track record of our starting with only one guest. And no, did that happen with that? Did that happen with Patricia and Chandler?
So strap in, enjoy. And in two weeks' time, hopefully we'll be back to crystal clear audio for the duration of the full podcast. All right. Well, maybe we should just go ahead and get started. I mean, this will be the second time out of three times that we've had two guests on where one of the guests did not show up. So we got a really bad track record. We're at a 67% track record of our starting with only one guest. And no, did that happen with that? Did that happen with Patricia and Chandler?|||所以系好安全带，尽情享受吧。两周后，希望我们在整个播客期间能恢复水晶般清晰的音频。好的。嗯，也许我们应该直接开始吧。我的意思是，这是我们三次邀请两位嘉宾中，其中一位嘉宾没有出现的第二次了。所以我们的记录真的很差。我们有一半以上、即 67% 的记录是以只有一位嘉宾开始的。不对，那次发生过吗？帕特里夏和钱德勒那次发生过吗？
Oh, no. Four times. Whoops. My bad. Boom. Boom. All right. So, yeah, if the avid listener will be trying to think in their head.
Oh, no. Four times. Whoops. My bad. Boom. Boom. All right. So, yeah, if the avid listener will be trying to think in their head.|||哦，不。四次。哎呀。我的错。咚。咚。好吧。所以，是的，如果是热心的听众会在脑子里思考。
So, yeah, we had Patricia. And when we had when we had Eric and his dad, they were both on. Yeah. So it seems like when you're there except for today both guests show up but when we did the c++ now recording which you weren't there for because you were busy working on your talk um tony didn't show up until like halfway through so that's typical tony i mean is that is he the only canadian of all of the folks that we just mentioned so maybe it's a canadian thing although jason you're canadian right i'm dual i have both
So, yeah, we had Patricia. And when we had when we had Eric and his dad, they were both on. Yeah. So it seems like when you're there except for today both guests show up but when we did the c++ now recording which you weren't there for because you were busy working on your talk um tony didn't show up until like halfway through so that's typical tony i mean is that is he the only canadian of all of the folks that we just mentioned so maybe it's a canadian thing although jason you're canadian right i'm dual i have both|||所以，是的，我们有帕特里夏。当我们邀请埃里克和他的爸爸时，他们两个都来了。是的。所以看起来当你不在场时——除了今天——两位嘉宾都出现了，但是当我们进行 C++ Now 录音时——你不在，因为你忙着准备你的演讲——嗯，托尼直到大概进行到一半才出现，所以这很符合托尼的风格。我的意思是，在我们刚才提到的所有人里，他是唯一的加拿大人吗？所以也许这是加拿大人的特色，虽然杰森你是加拿大人，对吧？我是双重国籍，两个都有。
so that's why that's why you showed up on time trony vanner does not show up late he shows up exactly when he's needed no he was needed at the beginning this happened all the time on the c++ committee where like you'd be in a room and you'd be talking about something and then very suddenly like tony would like ask some question and you'd be like oh when did tony get here and it's always like a really important question no i'm gonna stick with my theory that only the canadians have not shown up. And potentially we'll be two for two on Canadians showing up mid-podcast. Yeah.
so that's why that's why you showed up on time trony vanner does not show up late he shows up exactly when he's needed no he was needed at the beginning this happened all the time on the c++ committee where like you'd be in a room and you'd be talking about something and then very suddenly like tony would like ask some question and you'd be like oh when did tony get here and it's always like a really important question no i'm gonna stick with my theory that only the canadians have not shown up. And potentially we'll be two for two on Canadians showing up mid-podcast. Yeah.|||所以这就是为什么你准时出现的原因。托尼·万纳从来不会迟到，他在最需要的时候准时出现。不，一开始就需要他。在 C++ 委员会里这种事经常发生，比如你在一个房间里谈论某事，然后突然之间，托尼就会问一些问题，你会觉得，哦，托尼是什么时候来的？而且这总是一个非常重要的问题。不，我要坚持我的理论，只有中国……哦不，只有加拿大人没有出现。（笑）而且我们很可能会迎来两次都是加拿大人在播客中途出现的情况。是的。
Because I don't think, yeah, I don't think Patricia and Chandler. So speaking of C++ Now, C++ Now is coming up in two weeks. It's coming up in two weeks. The program was just published. I'm going to be giving a talk there about C++ standard parallelism, all the cool parallel programming features in C++ and all the cool parallel programming features that we're planning to add to C++
Because I don't think, yeah, I don't think Patricia and Chandler. So speaking of C++ Now, C++ Now is coming up in two weeks. It's coming up in two weeks. The program was just published. I'm going to be giving a talk there about C++ standard parallelism, all the cool parallel programming features in C++ and all the cool parallel programming features that we're planning to add to C++|||因为我觉得，对，我不觉得帕特里夏和钱德勒……所以说到 C++ Now，C++ Now 两周后就要举行了。两周后就要举行了。日程刚发布。我将在那里做一场关于 C++ 标准并行性的演讲，谈谈 C++ 中所有酷炫的并行编程特性，以及我们计划添加到 C++ 中的所有酷炫的并行编程特性……
in the next few years. And there's some very exciting keynotes. And I just think it's going to be a great program. It'll be really cool because the first time I went to Aspen was for BoostCon 2011, which was the conference before C++ Now. And it was a two-track conference at the time, and it was about maybe 50 or 60 people. And this year, C++ Now will be a two-track conference, and it'll be about that same number of people. So it'll be the same size and scale as when I first attended back at the start of my career.
in the next few years. And there's some very exciting keynotes. And I just think it's going to be a great program. It'll be really cool because the first time I went to Aspen was for BoostCon 2011, which was the conference before C++ Now. And it was a two-track conference at the time, and it was about maybe 50 or 60 people. And this year, C++ Now will be a two-track conference, and it'll be about that same number of people. So it'll be the same size and scale as when I first attended back at the start of my career.|||在未来几年里。还有一些非常激动人心的主旨演讲。我只是觉得这将是一个很棒的议程。这会非常酷，因为我第一次去阿斯彭是为了参加 BoostCon 2011，那是 C++ Now 之前的会议。当时这是一个双轨会议，大概有 50 或 60 人。而今年，C++ Now 将是一个双轨会议，人数也差不多是那个水平。所以它的规模和体量将与我职业生涯开始时初次参加时一样。
So I'm excited for it. Are you excited for another conference too, Bryce? I am excited for another conference. I'm actually very excited for C++ North. So I'll tell you how excited very excited for C++ North. So I'll tell you how excited I am for C++ North. C++ North, the last day of the conference
So I'm excited for it. Are you excited for another conference too, Bryce? I am excited for another conference. I'm actually very excited for C++ North. So I'll tell you how excited very excited for C++ North. So I'll tell you how excited I am for C++ North. C++ North, the last day of the conference|||所以我对此很兴奋。布莱斯，你也对另一个会议感到兴奋吗？我很期待另一个会议。实际上我非常期待 C++ North。所以我来告诉你我有多期待……非常期待 C++ North。所以我来告诉你我有多期待 C++ North。C++ North，会议的最后一天……
is July 20th. And July 21st is a national holiday in the US because it's my birthday. And I am choosing to go to C++ North and spend my birthday in Canada, which is like a big deal. I think I saw the tweet on this. I think I saw the tweet on this where you were asking for recommendations for restaurants.
is July 20th. And July 21st is a national holiday in the US because it's my birthday. And I am choosing to go to C++ North and spend my birthday in Canada, which is like a big deal. I think I saw the tweet on this. I think I saw the tweet on this where you were asking for recommendations for restaurants.|||是 7 月 20 日。而 7 月 21 日是美国的全国法定假日，因为那是我的生日。我选择去 C++ North，并在加拿大度过我的生日，这可是一件大事。我想我看到过关于这个的推文。我想我看到过你询问餐厅推荐的那条推文。
I have already selected the restaurant that Connor is taking me to for my birthday, which is Aloe, which is supposed to be the nicest restaurant in Canada. You know, I was thinking yesterday, and we haven't even introduced our solo guest of the two that did show up, but I was already yesterday thinking, how quickly, when we get to the topic of CPP North, is Bryce going to mention his birthday? Will we even get to anything about CPP North before that comes up? And listener, you have not been disappointed. It was, I mean, I want to say it was almost negative time to CPP North.
I have already selected the restaurant that Connor is taking me to for my birthday, which is Aloe, which is supposed to be the nicest restaurant in Canada. You know, I was thinking yesterday, and we haven't even introduced our solo guest of the two that did show up, but I was already yesterday thinking, how quickly, when we get to the topic of CPP North, is Bryce going to mention his birthday? Will we even get to anything about CPP North before that comes up? And listener, you have not been disappointed. It was, I mean, I want to say it was almost negative time to CPP North.|||我已经选好了康纳要带我去过生日的餐厅，那就是 Aloe，据说那是加拿大最好的餐厅。你知道，我昨天在想——我们甚至还没有介绍出席的那两位中唯一的嘉宾——但我昨天就在想，当聊到 CPP North 这个话题时，布莱斯会有多快提到他的生日？在提到这个之前，我们甚至能聊到任何关于 CPP North 的内容吗？听众朋友们，你们没有失望。那是……我的意思是，我想说几乎是负时间就扯到了 CPP North。
It was CPP North and then boom. You know why I'm really excited about this conference? And I got to say, Bryce, you did not disappoint. I had high expectations for you and you delivered. You delivered. But it's going to be conference day, conference day, conference day, birthday. So it's just going to be a big party. But yes, let's introduce Jason Walter.
It was CPP North and then boom. You know why I'm really excited about this conference? And I got to say, Bryce, you did not disappoint. I had high expectations for you and you delivered. You delivered. But it's going to be conference day, conference day, conference day, birthday. So it's just going to be a big party. But yes, let's introduce Jason Walter.|||刚提到 CPP North，然后砰的一下。你知道为什么我对这个会议真的很兴奋吗？我得说，布莱斯，你没有让人失望。我对你抱有很高的期望，你做到了。你真的做到了。但这将会是会议日、会议日、会议日、生日。所以这将会是一场盛大的派对。不过是的，让我们介绍一下杰森·沃尔特（Jason Walter）。
I don't actually know, Jason, if there are different titles on the board members for CPP North or if you are just a board member or do you have a special title for? No special title. No special title? Just a director. Just a director? Yeah, just a director. Just a director? Yeah, just a director. So yeah, maybe you want to introduce yourself and talk about how CPP North started,
I don't actually know, Jason, if there are different titles on the board members for CPP North or if you are just a board member or do you have a special title for? No special title. No special title? Just a director. Just a director? Yeah, just a director. Just a director? Yeah, just a director. So yeah, maybe you want to introduce yourself and talk about how CPP North started,|||杰森，我其实不知道在 CPP North 的董事会成员中是否有不同的头衔，还是你只是一个董事会成员，或者你有什么特殊的头衔？没有特殊头衔。没有特殊头衔？只是董事。只是董事？对，只是董事。只是董事？对，只是董事。所以，是的，也许你想自我介绍一下，并谈谈 CPP North 是如何开始的……
as I'm sure most of our listeners know that this is the first time this conference will be taking place. And I think the first ever C++ conference in Canada? Yeah, I believe so. I think this will be the first C++ conference in Canada. Yeah. At least I'm not aware of another one. Yeah, so I guess I'll start back the origin story. We'll do the origin story here. So a colleague of mine, Mike Dom, he and I were working on a project together at Autodesk. And I think there was one day that we were together. And I remember him looking up and was like, is there a C++ meetup in Toronto?
as I'm sure most of our listeners know that this is the first time this conference will be taking place. And I think the first ever C++ conference in Canada? Yeah, I believe so. I think this will be the first C++ conference in Canada. Yeah. At least I'm not aware of another one. Yeah, so I guess I'll start back the origin story. We'll do the origin story here. So a colleague of mine, Mike Dom, he and I were working on a project together at Autodesk. And I think there was one day that we were together. And I remember him looking up and was like, is there a C++ meetup in Toronto?|||因为我确信我们的大多数听众都知道，这是该会议第一次举办。而且我认为这也是加拿大的第一个 C++ 会议？是的，我相信是的。我认为这将是加拿大的第一个 C++ 会议。是的。至少我不知道还有别的。是的，我想我还是从起源故事开始讲起吧。我们在这里讲讲起源故事。所以我的一个同事，迈克·多姆（Mike Dom），我和他曾在欧特克（Autodesk）一起做一个项目。我想有一天我们在一起时，我记得他抬起头说，多伦多有 C++ 线下聚会吗？
And he was actively searching for a C++ meetup in the Toronto area. And he actually found that there was one that had been started a long time ago. But the person who had been organizing it had since left Toronto. And it was kind of just a stale meetup. So he kind of went off and he's like, I'm going to restart this. So he actually went out and reached out to the person had originally started the meetup, took over the meetup page, um, and started organizing, uh, actual meetups. And then along the way, he's like, do you want to, you know, co-organize with me? And I'm like,
And he was actively searching for a C++ meetup in the Toronto area. And he actually found that there was one that had been started a long time ago. But the person who had been organizing it had since left Toronto. And it was kind of just a stale meetup. So he kind of went off and he's like, I'm going to restart this. So he actually went out and reached out to the person had originally started the meetup, took over the meetup page, um, and started organizing, uh, actual meetups. And then along the way, he's like, do you want to, you know, co-organize with me? And I'm like,|||他一直在积极寻找多伦多地区的 C++ 聚会。他实际上发现有一个很久以前就开始的聚会。但组织它的那个人后来离开了多伦多。那基本上成了一个停滞不前的聚会。所以他去查了查，心想：我要重新开始这个聚会。于是他真的去找了最初发起这个聚会的人，接管了聚会页面，嗯，并开始组织真正的聚会。然后在这个过程中，他说：你想不想，你知道的，和我一起组织？我说……
yeah, sure. I'll help out. Like I kind of in the the mission of like inclusion and learning and uh just you know community we thought that toronto was a great c++ development community so it kind of started organically from there although mike will say that he always kind of had the plan for a conference and i was a bit resistant to it like i was like a conference sounds like a lot of work. Um, and you know, over time I, I kind of thought, yeah, I think we could do a conference here and I think there, it would be a great conference to do. So, um, about, um, two years ago, we kind of, you know, organized ourselves under the, uh, an organization called CBP Toronto.
yeah, sure. I'll help out. Like I kind of in the the mission of like inclusion and learning and uh just you know community we thought that toronto was a great c++ development community so it kind of started organically from there although mike will say that he always kind of had the plan for a conference and i was a bit resistant to it like i was like a conference sounds like a lot of work. Um, and you know, over time I, I kind of thought, yeah, I think we could do a conference here and I think there, it would be a great conference to do. So, um, about, um, two years ago, we kind of, you know, organized ourselves under the, uh, an organization called CBP Toronto.|||行啊，没问题。我会帮忙的。就像我们本着包容、学习以及，嗯，你知道的，社区的宗旨，我们认为多伦多是一个很棒的 C++ 开发社区，所以它就顺其自然地从那里开始了。尽管迈克会说他其实一直都有办会议的计划，而我当时有点抗拒，觉得办会议听起来像是一堆麻烦事。嗯，你知道的，随着时间的推移，我慢慢觉得，对，我觉得我们可以在这里办一个会议，而且我觉得这会是一个很棒的会议。所以，大约两年前，我们，你知道的，在名为 CBP Toronto 的组织下把大家组织在了一起。
We officially called it cpp toronto and then we established a board of directors so uh mike and i were on the the first board of directors and then we invited um uh three others so k gregory uh she has been an excellent advisor for us uh all along the way um i'm gonna butcher their names and I'm going to apologize now because I always butcher names. Natalie Liebenson and Diana Oeda were also asked to join. And so we started organizing meetups together as a board and then started planning a C++ conference. So the original goal was to do a conference in July of 2021. But obviously, there were things happening around the world that were not a good time to plan a public get-together or event. And so we decided, you know, let's put a stake in the ground and do our first conference in July of this year, July 2022.
We officially called it cpp toronto and then we established a board of directors so uh mike and i were on the the first board of directors and then we invited um uh three others so k gregory uh she has been an excellent advisor for us uh all along the way um i'm gonna butcher their names and I'm going to apologize now because I always butcher names. Natalie Liebenson and Diana Oeda were also asked to join. And so we started organizing meetups together as a board and then started planning a C++ conference. So the original goal was to do a conference in July of 2021. But obviously, there were things happening around the world that were not a good time to plan a public get-together or event. And so we decided, you know, let's put a stake in the ground and do our first conference in July of this year, July 2022.|||我们正式将其命名为 cpp toronto，然后我们成立了董事会。所以，嗯，我和迈克是第一届董事会成员，然后我们邀请了，嗯，其他三个人，凯·格里高利（K Gregory），嗯，她一路上都是我们极好的顾问——嗯，我要把他们的名字念砸了，我先道个歉，因为我总是把名字念错。娜塔莉·利宾森（Natalie Liebenson）和黛安娜·奥埃达（Diana Oeda）也被邀请加入。于是我们作为董事会开始共同组织聚会，然后开始筹划 C++ 会议。所以最初的目标是在 2021 年 7 月举办会议。但显然，当时世界各地发生了一些事情，并不是筹划公开聚会或活动的好时机。所以我们决定，你知道的，下定决心，在今年 7 月、即 2022 年 7 月举办我们的第一届会议。
So that's where we are. So, I mean, and our mission all along has kind of been having a place that people can connect and learn and have fun about C++. You know, we were doing meetups in person, and then we did them virtually and we invited, you know, the world to do those virtually with us.
So that's where we are. So, I mean, and our mission all along has kind of been having a place that people can connect and learn and have fun about C++. You know, we were doing meetups in person, and then we did them virtually and we invited, you0 know, the world to do those virtually with us.|||这就是我们目前的现状。所以，我的意思是，我们的使命一直都是为人们提供一个可以联系、学习并享受 C++ 乐趣的场所。你知道的，我们以前举行面对面的聚会，后来我们在网上举行，并且我们邀请了，你知道的，全世界的人和我们一起在线参与。
And we now wanted to just invite the world to come to Toronto, which we think is a great place to kind of, you know, that kind of underlines the themes that we have. Like we believe in diversity, inclusion, culture, you know, and anyone, we believe anyone should, should be able
And we now wanted to just invite the world to come to Toronto, which we think is a great place to kind of, you know, that kind of underlines the themes that we have. Like we believe in diversity, inclusion, culture, you know, and anyone, we believe anyone should, should be able|||而现在我们只想邀请全世界来到多伦多，我们认为这是一个很棒的地方，你知道的，它突出了我们的主题。比如我们相信多样性、包容性、文化，你知道的，任何人，我们相信任何人都应该能够……
to learn C++ and be a part of the community. So that's, that's where we are now. So we're looking forward to inviting people. That's great. Yeah. And I think, I think I participated in one of the C++ Toronto virtual meetups. I feel like you participated in a couple. You did one of the debates. I can't remember if you were the moderator or the person making arguments. I think maybe one time you were a moderator and one time you were arguing. There was like, what belongs in the C++
to learn C++ and be a part of the community. So that's, that's where we are now. So we're looking forward to inviting people. That's great. Yeah. And I think, I think I participated in one of the C++ Toronto virtual meetups. I feel like you participated in a couple. You did one of the debates. I can't remember if you were the moderator or the person making arguments. I think maybe one time you were a moderator and one time you were arguing. There was like, what belongs in the C++|||学习 C++ 并成为社区的一部分。所以这就是我们目前的状况。因此我们期待着邀请大家。太棒了。是的。而且我想，我想我参加过一次 C++ Toronto 的线上聚会。我觉得你参加了好几次。你参加过其中一场辩论。我记不清你是主持人还是辩论者。我觉得可能有一回你是主持人，有一回你在辩论。当时的主题类似：什么应该属于 C++……
standard library? I feel like Tony and you were both on a panel because you were going back and forth. That's right. I think, yes, it's the first Conference of Canada, but I think it's another first, which is, I believe it's the first C++ conference on the eastern seaboard, unless time zone at least. Oh, yeah. Yeah, that is true. That's a good point.
standard library? I feel like Tony and you were both on a panel because you were going back and forth. That's right. I think, yes, it's the first Conference of Canada, but I think it's another first, which is, I believe it's the first C++ conference on the eastern seaboard, unless time zone at least. Oh, yeah. Yeah, that is true. That's a good point.|||标准库？我觉得托尼和你都在专家小组里，因为你们两个争论来着。没错。我想，是的，这是加拿大的第一个会议，但我觉得这也是另一个第一，那就是，我相信这是东海岸的第一个 C++ 会议，至少在时区上是这样。哦，对。是的，确实如此。这倒是个好点子。
How come New York's not had a conference? There have been some talks about a Gotham C++ conference. Look at this. The two podcast hosts of ADSP setting up rival conferences, probably at the same time in the future. You know, when we were considering new locations for CppCon, the finalist locations were sort of either going to be this, the Denver location that was selected. And the other location I think was going to be somewhere in Atlanta.
How come New York's not had a conference? There have been some talks about a Gotham C++ conference. Look at this. The two podcast hosts of ADSP setting up rival conferences, probably at the same time in the future. You know, when we were considering new locations for CppCon, the finalist locations were sort of either going to be this, the Denver location that was selected. And the other location I think was going to be somewhere in Atlanta.|||怎么纽约一直没有举办过会议？曾有一些关于筹办哥谭 C++ 会议（Gotham C++ conference）的讨论。看这个。ADSP 的两个播客主持人要在未来同期举办竞争对手级别的会议。你知道的，当我们考虑 CppCon 的新举办地点时，入围的候选地点要么是这个，最终被选中的丹佛。另一个地点我记得好像是亚特兰大的某个地方。
And I think that would have been great. Yeah. But the, you know, there's having the conference on the Eastern seaboard I think is, is great because it's easier for folks from Europe to get there. And it's not that much of a stretch for West coast folks to get there. And it's not that much of a stretch for West Coast folks to get there. Obviously, it makes it harder for anybody from Asia to attend the conference. But I think it was already pretty challenging if you were to go to something like, you know, CppCon if you were in Japan. Whereas if you're in London going to C++ North versus something like CppCon when it was in Seattle, you'll cut the flight time in half basically.
And I think that would have been great. Yeah. But the, you know, there's having the conference on the Eastern seaboard I think is, is great because it's easier for folks from Europe to get there. And it's not that much of a stretch for West coast folks to get there. And it's not that much of a stretch for West Coast folks to get there. Obviously, it makes it harder for anybody from Asia to attend the conference. But I think it was already pretty challenging if you were to go to something like, you know, CppCon if you were in Japan. Whereas if you're in London going to C++ North versus something like CppCon when it was in Seattle, you'll cut the flight time in half basically.|||而且我觉得那本来会很棒。是的。但是，你知道的，把会议设在东海岸我认为非常好，因为欧洲的朋友去那里会更方便。而且对西海岸的朋友来说，去那里也不是什么太大的负担。对西海岸的朋友来说，去那里也不是什么太大的负担。显然，这会让任何来自亚洲的人参加会议变得更难。但我想如果你在日本，要去像 CppCon 这样的会议本身就已经相当具有挑战性了。而如果你在伦敦，去参加 C++ North，相比去在西雅图举办的 CppCon，你的飞行时间基本上可以减少一半。
So I think we'll see more of an international audience at this conference. No, and I think Toronto is a very accessible city across the world, like a lot of direct, like it's the largest airport in Canada. So, you know, a lot of flights come in, it's very easy to get to from Europe and from, you know, Asia, even there's direct flights from Asia into Toronto. It can also be easier for an international audience to get a tourist or a travel visa to go into Canada than it can be in some cases to get into the U.S. Look at this. Bryce is putting together like a little pitching deck for us. I never even thought about that. But it's true that the first time I flew to Europe from Toronto, I was confused on why it only took like five or six hours, because every time in my life I had flown to Europe at
So I think we'll see more of an international audience at this conference. No, and I think Toronto is a very accessible city across the world, like a lot of direct, like it's the largest airport in Canada. So, you know, a lot of flights come in, it's very easy to get to from Europe and from, you know, Asia, even there's direct flights from Asia into Toronto. It can also be easier for an international audience to get a tourist or a travel visa to go into Canada than it can be in some cases to get into the U.S. Look at this. Bryce is putting together like a little pitching deck for us. I never even thought about that. But it's true that the first time I flew to Europe from Toronto, I was confused on why it only took like five or six hours, because every time in my life I had flown to Europe at|||所以我想我们会在这次会议上看到更多国际观众。不，而且我认为多伦多是一个面向全球交通非常便利的城市，有很多直达航班，比如它是加拿大最大的机场。所以，你知道的，有很多航班飞进来，从欧洲和，你知道的，亚洲去那里都很容易，甚至有从亚洲直飞多伦多的航班。对国际观众来说，申请去加拿大的旅游或旅行签证，有时可能比申请去美国更容易。看看这个。布莱斯正在为我们准备一个小型的推介幻灯片。我以前甚至都没想过这一点。但确实，我第一次从多伦多飞往欧洲时，我很困惑为什么只花了五六个小时，因为我这辈子每次飞往欧洲时……
that point, I had been on the West Coast, which is like an extra whatever, you know, three, four or five hours, depending on exactly where you are. And I was like, I remember taking longer to get to Europe. But obviously, that's because you're on the other side of the country, which at the time I had not put together. So. So, yeah, it's very exciting. I mean, Canada is one of the great, you know, C++ hubs. So I suspect you'll see a lot of local Canadian programmers there. We even, if you look at Toronto itself, I mean, there's been some recent news articles that identify Toronto as one of the fastest growing tech centers in North America now. Compared to San Francisco, New York, Austin, you know, all the big places, you know, Toronto is
that point, I had been on the West Coast, which is like an extra whatever, you know, three, four or five hours, depending on exactly where you are. And I was like, I remember taking longer to get to Europe. But obviously, that's because you're on the other side of the country, which at the time I had not put together. So. So, yeah, it's very exciting. I mean, Canada is one of the great, you know, C++ hubs. So I suspect you'll see a lot of local Canadian programmers there. We even, if you look at Toronto itself, I mean, there's been some recent news articles that identify Toronto as one of the fastest growing tech centers in North America now. Compared to San Francisco, New York, Austin, you know, all the big places, you know, Toronto is|||当时都在西海岸，那就要多花个三四五个小时不等，具体取决于你到底在哪个位置。当时我就想，我记得去欧洲要花更长时间。但很显然，那是由于你在国家的另一边，当时我还没把这两者联系起来。所以。所以，是的，这非常令人兴奋。我的意思是，加拿大是伟大的，你知道的，C++ 中心之一。所以我猜你会看到很多当地的加拿大程序员在那里。我们甚至——如果你看看多伦多本身，我的意思是，最近有一些新闻文章将多伦多列为北美发展最快的科技中心之一。与旧金山、纽约、奥斯汀，你知道的，所有这些大地方相比，你知道的，多伦多……
right up there. So it does seem like there's a real exodus from, from the Bay Area, like half of my colleagues have moved to New York around the same time that I did. Yeah, aren't there several different like, you know, of the FANG or MANG or, you know, MANIA or whatever the acronyms are? Like, I think Google, they're building a big office actually right by the hotel that the conference is taking place at. And I think there's some purported number of jobs that they're bringing into the city with that building. And I feel like there's a couple other companies as well that are you know setting up shop I think Toronto was on the short list of companies for Amazon's h hq2 which they obviously didn't end up getting but which may or may not have been a good thing or bad thing depending on who you ask um and you know we had we had we hosted a committee meeting in Toronto I feel like uh it was the summer of 2016 um maybe maybe there's going to be another committee meeting in uh uh in the future because hey all i'm saying if we did if we did c++ north around the same time in year uh in 2023 that's around the time when the c++ committee meets yeah so i could have you could do the committee meeting the week before and then everybody come
right up there. So it does seem like there's a real exodus from, from the Bay Area, like half of my colleagues have moved to New York around the same time that I did. Yeah, aren't there several different like, you know, of the FANG or MANG or, you know, MANIA or whatever the acronyms are? Like, I think Google, they're building a big office actually right by the hotel that the conference is taking place at. And I think there's some purported number of jobs that they're bringing into the city with that building. And I feel like there's a couple other companies as well that are you know setting up shop I think Toronto was on the short list of companies for Amazon's h hq2 which they obviously didn't end up getting but which may or may not have been a good thing or bad thing depending on who you ask um and you know we had we had we hosted a committee meeting in Toronto I feel like uh it was the summer of 2016 um maybe maybe there's going to be another committee meeting in uh uh in the future because hey all i'm saying if we did if we did c++ north around the same time in year uh in 2023 that's around the time when the c++ committee meets yeah so i could have you could do the committee meeting the week before and then everybody come|||绝对名列前茅。所以看起来确实有大量人从湾区流出，就像我的一半同事和我差不多同时搬到了纽约。是啊，难道没有几个不同的，你知道的，像 FANG、MANG 或者 MANIA 之类的缩写吗？比如，我认为谷歌实际上正在会议举办酒店旁边建造一个大办公室。而且我认为随着那栋建筑的落成，他们会为这座城市带来据称数量的就业机会。而且我觉得还有好几家其他公司也正在，你知道的，安营扎寨。我觉得多伦多曾在亚马逊第二总部（HQ2）的候选名单上，他们最终显然没能拿下，但这究竟是件好事还是坏事取决于你问谁。嗯，你知道的，我们曾举办过，我们在多伦多举办过一次委员会会议，我记得，那是 2016 年的夏天，嗯，也许，也许以后还会有另一次委员会会议，因为，嘿，我只想说，如果我们把 C++ North 安排在 2023 年同年的那个时候举办，那差不多就是 C++ 委员会开会的时间。是的，所以你可以，你可以把委员会会议安排在提前一周，然后大家都可以来……
to the conference i would be more than happy to invite you know have the committee come up here and yes we are planning on it there'll be a 2023 edition of cpp north um so wasn't there or maybe this maybe i'm not recalling this correctly but at one point in time was the tentative plan like wasn't there a plan Montreal committee meeting and then uh the conference was going to be juxtaposed with that was that the tentative plan or is that we had I think we did reach out to the committee and they they had plans to meet in either Montreal or New York City like I think I can't remember exactly there wasn't montreal actually you're right there was prior to covid there was a montreal meeting scheduled for the 2021
to the conference i would be more than happy to invite you know have the committee come up here and yes we are planning on it there'll be a 2023 edition of cpp north um so wasn't there or maybe this maybe i'm not recalling this correctly but at one point in time was the tentative plan like wasn't there a plan Montreal committee meeting and then uh the conference was going to be juxtaposed with that was that the tentative plan or is that we had I think we did reach out to the committee and they they had plans to meet in either Montreal or New York City like I think I can't remember exactly there wasn't montreal actually you're right there was prior to covid there was a montreal meeting scheduled for the 2021|||参加会议。我非常乐意邀请，你知道的，让委员会来这里开会。是的，我们正在计划中，2023 年还会有 cpp north。嗯，难道之前没有过，或者也许我记不太清了，但曾经一度暂定的计划是——难道没有过蒙特利尔委员会会议的计划，然后会议要与那相邻举办吗？那是暂定计划吗？还是说我们曾——我想我们确实联系过委员会，他们曾计划在蒙特利尔或纽约市开会，好像是——我记不太清了，那次不是在蒙特利尔。实际上你是对的，在疫情之前，原定于 2021 年召开蒙特利尔会议。
yeah uh time frame and i think that's you know we kind of aligned our dates around that initially and um and then there was a new york one the next year which we were kind of aligning with but then that obviously also yeah unfortunately although that was not a new york meeting that was a jfk meeting a what it was a meeting at the jfk airport i know i i actually was pretty excited because it was at the old it was there's this hotel at the old twa terminal at jfk and that's where where we were going to host the meeting and it's supposed to be a really cool hotel a lot of aviation history history. As Connor knows, I love planes. This is true. I love planes.
yeah uh time frame and i think that's you know we kind of aligned our dates around that initially and um and then there was a new york one the next year which we were kind of aligning with but then that obviously also yeah unfortunately although that was not a new york meeting that was a jfk meeting a what it was a meeting at the jfk airport i know i i actually was pretty excited because it was at the old it was there's this hotel at the old twa terminal at jfk and that's where where we were going to host the meeting and it's supposed to be a really cool hotel a lot of aviation history history. As Connor knows, I love planes. This is true. I love planes.|||是的，嗯，时间框架是这样的。我想这就是，你知道的，我们最初是围绕这个来调整我们的日期的，嗯，然后第二年有一个纽约的会议，我们也差不多是按那个来调整的。但后来那显然也——是的，不幸的是，虽然那不是一个纽约市内的会议，而是一个肯尼迪机场（JFK）的会议。什么？那是开在肯尼迪机场的会议。我知道，我其实挺兴奋的，因为它是设在旧的——肯尼迪机场旧的 TWA 航站楼那里有一家酒店，我们原本打算在那里举办会议，据说那是一家非常酷的酒店，有很多航空历史。正如康纳所知，我喜欢飞机。千真万确。我喜欢飞机。
Now, the only problem is I literally would have had to stay at the hotel. It is impractical to commute from Manhattan to JFK every day. It would be like an hour and a half if I took the train. And it would probably be as long if i took a cab and also be very expensive this won't surprise the listener but uh when bryce i've been at an airport with bryce and bryce likes to sit by the window and identify the 747 737s and he says i've got five planes out there he refers to them as his planes and i'm like what are you talking about bryce and he's those are my planes you know he's all right that's what 737 it's a whatever whatever oh this is awesome this is awesome which which lounge when was that bryce not even paying attention not even paying attention what just happened bryce i see i see when was that i'm
Now, the only problem is I literally would have had to stay at the hotel. It is impractical to commute from Manhattan to JFK every day. It would be like an hour and a half if I took the train. And it would probably be as long if i took a cab and also be very expensive this won't surprise the listener but uh when bryce i've been at an airport with bryce and bryce likes to sit by the window and identify the 747 737s and he says i've got five planes out there he refers to them as his planes and i'm like what are you talking about bryce and he's those are my planes you know he's all right that's what 737 it's a whatever whatever oh this is awesome this is awesome which which lounge when was that bryce not even paying attention not even paying attention what just happened bryce i see i see when was that i'm|||现在，唯一的问题是我真的必须住在那个酒店里。每天从曼哈顿通勤到肯尼迪机场是不切实际的。如果坐火车单程就要一个半小时左右。如果打车可能也得花那么长时间，而且非常昂贵。听众听到这个可能不会惊讶，但——嗯，当布莱斯——我和布莱斯一起去过机场，布莱斯喜欢坐在窗户边，辨认 747 和 737，然后他说：“外面有五架飞机。”他把它们称为“我的飞机”，而我说：“布莱斯你在说什么呢？”他说：“那是我的飞机，你知道的。”他接着说：“好吧，那是 737，那是随便什么什么……”哦，这太棒了，这太棒了！在哪个贵宾室？那是什——布莱斯甚至都没在听！甚至没在听！刚刚发生什么了？布莱斯？我明白了，我明白了。那是什——我……
trying to remember when was that on the flight to to remember. When was that? On the flight to, it was in, it was in the crazy Europe trip of 2019. Yeah. In early November. Were we on the same plane? Were we sitting next to each other? We were at one point.
trying to remember when was that on the flight to to remember. When was that? On the flight to, it was in, it was in the crazy Europe trip of 2019. Yeah. In early November. Were we on the same plane? Were we sitting next to each other? We were at one point.|||在努力回想，那是哪一次？在去……的航班上。那是哪一次？在去……的航班上，那是，那是 2019 年那次疯狂的欧洲之旅中。是的。在 11 月初。我们当时在同一架飞机上吗？我们当时坐在一起吗？我们有一段时间是坐在一起的。
Cause you were trying to write some algorithm and you were like, I need your input on this. And I was like, I just want to read a book, but we have, we have to welcome. I was right. I had a theory. What? Or Bryce, you need to say But we have to welcome. I was right. I had a theory.
Cause you were trying to write some algorithm and you were like, I need your input on this. And I was like, I just want to read a book, but we have, we have to welcome. I was right. I had a theory. What? Or Bryce, you need to say But we have to welcome. I was right. I had a theory.|||因为你当时在试着写什么算法，然后你说：“我需要你对这个的意见。”而我想的是：“我只想读本书。”但是我们有——我们得欢迎……我猜得对。我有个理论。什么？或者布莱斯，你需要说：“但是我们得欢迎……我猜得对。我有个理论。”
Or Bryce, do you need to say something? Yeah, yeah. I was going to say one of the great things about C++ North is that it's not at the airport. It's right in the heart of the downtown area. It's in a really good location. We've got lots of great quotes from Bryce here. It's a great international conference, easier to get into Canada, and it's not at an airport. And Patrice wasn't here for this earlier, but I had a theory that all of our Canadian guests, when invited on with another, they like to show up halfway through because there's another well-known Canadian, Tony, that did this before.
Or Bryce, do you need to say something? Yeah, yeah. I was going to say one of the great things about C++ North is that it's not at the airport. It's right in the heart of the downtown area. It's in a really good location. We've got lots of great quotes from Bryce here. It's a great international conference, easier to get into Canada, and it's not at an airport. And Patrice wasn't here for this earlier, but I had a theory that all of our Canadian guests, when invited on with another, they like to show up halfway through because there's another well-known Canadian, Tony, that did this before.|||或者布莱斯，你需要说点什么吗？对，对。我本来想说，C++ North 的一大优点就是它不在机场。它就在市中心的腹地。地理位置非常好。我们这儿有好多布莱斯的精彩语录。这是一个伟大的国际会议，去加拿大更容易，而且它不在机场。而且帕特里斯刚才不在场，但我有个理论，我们所有的加拿大嘉宾，当和另一个人一起被邀请时，他们喜欢在中途才出现，因为之前有另一个著名的加拿大人托尼也这么干过。
And Patrice has now made it two for two. Welcome, Patrice. How's it going? Doing fine. I was planning on being there at 10. So I'm kind of lucky I saw your email. I looked earlier today and I had 10 in my inbox. Oh, maybe it was a time zone thing.
And Patrice has now made it two for two. Welcome, Patrice. How's it going? Doing fine. I was planning on being there at 10. So I'm kind of lucky I saw your email. I looked earlier today and I had 10 in my inbox. Oh, maybe it was a time zone thing.|||而帕特里斯现在让这个记录达到了二比二。欢迎，帕特里斯。最近怎么样？挺好的。我原本计划在 10 点到的。所以能看到你的电子邮件我挺走运的。我今天早些时候看了一眼，我的收件箱里写的是 10 点。哦，也许是时区的问题。
Oh, yeah. Because don't they have the skip ahead, skip behind or something? Yeah. Or a daylight saving time thing. We're all in the same time zone. I am there. I'm glad to be there. Hi there. Hey, how you doing? it's been a while since
Oh, yeah. Because don't they have the skip ahead, skip behind or something? Yeah. Or a daylight saving time thing. We're all in the same time zone. I am there. I'm glad to be there. Hi there. Hey, how you doing? it's been a while since|||哦，对。因为他们不是有什么向前跳、向后跳之类的吗？对。或者夏令时的问题。我们都在同一个时区。我到了。很高兴能来这里。大家好。嘿，最近怎么样？好久不见……
i've seen you you know those online meetings when you have a teaching schedule that they're kind of yeah yeah so we've got we've got professor patrice here and well okay here's another thing that that this is going to probably lead to more con edits, because I think that the answer here is in the negative. But is there a virtual option for C++ North if you want to attend the conference remotely? No, we decided we did not want to. Connor, you're going to have to cut this out later. Cut out this section right here. Why? It's a valuable information for the listener to know. Yeah. The stuff that I end up, you know, cutting out or cutting in. We've got a special
i've seen you you know those online meetings when you have a teaching schedule that they're kind of yeah yeah so we've got we've got professor patrice here and well okay here's another thing that that this is going to probably lead to more con edits, because I think that the answer here is in the negative. But is there a virtual option for C++ North if you want to attend the conference remotely? No, we decided we did not want to. Connor, you're going to have to cut this out later. Cut out this section right here. Why? It's a valuable information for the listener to know. Yeah. The stuff that I end up, you know, cutting out or cutting in. We've got a special|||我见过你了。你知道那些在线会议，当你排了教学日程时，它们有点……是啊，是啊。所以我们有，我们有帕特里斯教授在这里，嗯，好吧，这里还有一件事，这可能会导致康纳需要进行更多剪辑，因为我认为这里的答案是否定的。但是如果你想远程参加会议，C++ North 会议有虚拟参与选项吗？不，我们决定不提供。康纳，你待会儿得把这段剪掉。把这部分直接剪掉。为什么？这对听众来说是有价值的信息。是啊。我最终，你知道的，剪掉或保留的内容。我们有一个特别的……
episode 200 coming for folks where if you listened to the last episode, I think it was episode 72. It ended right at a cliffhanger. We were talking about real serious life stuff and Bryce starts to go on a long-winded tangent about projecting his life into the future and so we're gonna release that in like three years because bryce don't even remember bryce makes some predictions he's like oh yeah by episode 200 that'll that'll definitely be the case for sure for sure oh yeah yeah yeah i now i remember yes yeah but we can't we can't talk about that too loud my mother is within within earshot oh yes yes that's fine we'll stay on topic all right so uh jason introduced or actually you didn't you introduced
episode 200 coming for folks where if you listened to the last episode, I think it was episode 72. It ended right at a cliffhanger. We were talking about real serious life stuff and Bryce starts to go on a long-winded tangent about projecting his life into the future and so we're gonna release that in like three years because bryce don't even remember bryce makes some predictions he's like oh yeah by episode 200 that'll that'll definitely be the case for sure for sure oh yeah yeah yeah i now i remember yes yeah but we can't we can't talk about that too loud my mother is within within earshot oh yes yes that's fine we'll stay on topic all right so uh jason introduced or actually you didn't you introduced|||第 200 期节目要带给大家，如果你听了上一期节目——我想是第 72 期。它在一个悬念处戛然而止。我们当时在谈论非常严肃的生活话题，然后布莱斯开始长篇大论地扯开话题，谈论他对未来生活的展望，所以我们打算在大概三年后发布那一期，因为布莱斯根本不记得了。布莱斯做了一些预测，他说：“哦，是的，到第 200 期时，那绝对会是那样，百分之百，百分之百。”哦，对，对，对，我现在想起来了。是的，是的。但是我们不能——我们不能太大声谈论这个，我母亲就在附近能听到。哦，对，对，没关系，我们还是聊正题吧。好吧，所以，嗯，杰森介绍了——或者其实你没有，你介绍了……
the conference um and you briefly you briefly sort of mentioned that you worked i think at autodesk but do you want to finish introducing yourself and then we'll hop to patrice and patrice can introduce himself yeah so i um now i work at epic games i'm on the virtual production uh team developing tools for um for virtual production workflows mostly centered around in-camera vfx right now um and so that's my primary responsibility there do you know tim tim tim sweeney i i've met i've met tim and you know he's a met Tim, and he's very nice. I mean, I have all positive things about Tim. He would be great.
the conference um and you briefly you briefly sort of mentioned that you worked i think at autodesk but do you want to finish introducing yourself and then we'll hop to patrice and patrice can introduce himself yeah so i um now i work at epic games i'm on the virtual production uh team developing tools for um for virtual production workflows mostly centered around in-camera vfx right now um and so that's my primary responsibility there do you know tim tim tim sweeney i i've met i've met tim and you know he's a met Tim, and he's very nice. I mean, I have all positive things about Tim. He would be great.|||这个会议，嗯，你刚才简短地提到过你好像在欧特克工作，但你想不想做完自我介绍，然后我们再转到帕特里斯那里，让帕特里斯做个自我介绍？好的，所以我，嗯，现在我在 Epic Games 工作，我在虚拟制作团队，负责开发用于虚拟制作工作流的工具，目前主要围绕机内视效（in-camera vfx）展开，嗯，这就是我在那里的主要职责。你认识蒂姆——蒂姆·斯威尼（Tim Sweeney）吗？我见过——我见过蒂姆，你知道的，他是一个……我见过蒂姆，他非常好。我的意思是，我对蒂姆只有积极的评价。他真的很棒。
We should get him the keynote at a future C++ North. That would be so cool. I mean, you'd be sort of like, what do you call that? Throwing spaghetti at the wall or shooting blindly? Because his takes on C++, they're kind of hit and miss if you follow him on Twitter. Yeah. But I, I just, I love that he is like a CEO and that he has hot takes on about C++ on
We should get him the keynote at a future C++ North. That would be so cool. I mean, you'd be sort of like, what do you call that? Throwing spaghetti at the wall or shooting blindly? Because his takes on C++, they're kind of hit and miss if you follow him on Twitter. Yeah. But I, I just, I love that he is like a CEO and that he has hot takes on about C++ on|||我们应该请他在未来的 C++ North 上做主旨演讲。那太酷了。我的意思是，你这就有点像——怎么说呢？把意大利面扔在墙上碰运气，还是盲目开枪？因为他对 C++ 的看法，如果你关注他的推特，就会发现有时准有时不准。是的。但我觉得——我就是喜欢他作为一个 CEO，却在推特上对 C++ 有各种犀利独到的见解……
Twitter. Like there's not a lot of CEOs that have hot takes about programming languages on Twitter. I'm just saying. That's true. Although that puts you in a boat with Elon Musk because he said things about programming languages. Please, let's not compare Tim Sweeney
Twitter. Like there's not a lot of CEOs that have hot takes about programming languages on Twitter. I'm just saying. That's true. Although that puts you in a boat with Elon Musk because he said things about programming languages. Please, let's not compare Tim Sweeney|||就像推特上没有几个 CEO 会对编程语言发表犀利评论。我只是这么说说。确实如此。不过这让你和埃隆·马斯克坐到了同一条船上，因为他也对编程语言发表过看法。拜托，咱们别把蒂姆·斯威尼和埃隆·马斯克相提并论……
and Elon Musk. Tim Sweeney is somebody that I have respect for. You know that he got a poster offer from Elon Musk at CBPCon at some point. It was really entertaining. It was really bad. All right. So now that you've just heard Patrice a couple
and Elon Musk. Tim Sweeney is somebody that I have respect for. You know that he got a poster offer from Elon Musk at CBPCon at some point. It was really entertaining. It was really bad. All right. So now that you've just heard Patrice a couple|||与埃隆·马斯克相提并论。蒂姆·斯威尼是我尊敬的人。你知道吗，他曾在某次 CppCon 上收到过埃隆·马斯克的挑衅海报。那真的挺搞笑的。真的很差劲。好吧。所以既然你们刚刚听帕特里斯说了几句……
of times, we'll throw it to you, Patrice. And for those of you that haven't picked up, Jason and I are both in Toronto, whereas Patrice is close. He's actually sort of in between New York and Toronto. So I'll throw it to you, Patrice. Yeah, so I'm about five hours-ish away from both of them.
of times, we'll throw it to you, Patrice. And for those of you that haven't picked up, Jason and I are both in Toronto, whereas Patrice is close. He's actually sort of in between New York and Toronto. So I'll throw it to you, Patrice. Yeah, so I'm about five hours-ish away from both of them.|||我们把话题交给你，帕特里斯。对于还没听出来的人说明一下，杰森和我都身在多伦多，而帕特里斯离得很近。他实际上差不多位于纽约和多伦多的中间。所以我把话筒交给你，帕特里斯。是的，我离他们两个大概都有五个小时左右的车程。
It's like a triangle. I'm in Montreal, yeah. So hi, I'm Patrice. I'm a professor, I'm a member of the committee, and I'm normally on time for my meetings. So where are you a professor? In two places. I have two full-time jobs. So I teach in a college named Collège, which is close to where I live, like a quarter by bus. And I also teach at Chabot University on two different campuses. One that's south of Montreal, which is public transit accessible, and one that's three hours drive away.
It's like a triangle. I'm in Montreal, yeah. So hi, I'm Patrice. I'm a professor, I'm a member of the committee, and I'm normally on time for my meetings. So where are you a professor? In two places. I have two full-time jobs. So I teach in a college named Collège, which is close to where I live, like a quarter by bus. And I also teach at Chabot University on two different campuses. One that's south of Montreal, which is public transit accessible, and one that's three hours drive away.|||就像一个三角形。我在蒙特利尔，是的。大家好，我是帕特里斯。我是一名教授，也是委员会成员，我开会通常都很准时。那你是在哪里当教授？在两个地方。我有两份全职工作。我在一所名叫 Collège 的学院教书，离我住的地方很近，坐公交车大概一刻钟。我还在夏博大学（Chabot University）的两个不同的校区教书。一个在蒙特利尔南部，坐公共交通可以到达，另一个开车要三小时。
So depending on the days, I drive a bit or I just take the bus. And so you're a full-time teaching professor. Two times, yeah. I have two full-time jobs, which makes keeping up with meetings a bit complicated sometimes. And do you teach C++? Well, yeah, yeah. In college, they put C++ away recently. They went to a more web-oriented kind of thing, so they do other languages more now.
So depending on the days, I drive a bit or I just take the bus. And so you're a full-time teaching professor. Two times, yeah. I have two full-time jobs, which makes keeping up with meetings a bit complicated sometimes. And do you teach C++? Well, yeah, yeah. In college, they put C++ away recently. They went to a more web-oriented kind of thing, so they do other languages more now.|||所以根据不同的日子，我会开会儿车或者直接坐公交。所以你是一位全职的教学教授。两份全职，是的。我有两份全职工作，这使得有时按时参加会议变得有点复杂。那你教 C++ 吗？嗯，是的，是的。在学院里，他们最近把 C++ 放下了。他们转向了更偏向网页开发的方向，所以他们现在更多地使用其他语言。
At university, I do only C++ stuff. I think this is the first time we've had an actual teacher on the program. Well, I'm glad to be the first. I hope I won't be the last. There are others, of course. Oh, yeah. I've been doing that for a long while. It's my 23rd year
At university, I do only C++ stuff. I think this is the first time we've had an actual teacher on the program. Well, I'm glad to be the first. I hope I won't be the last. There are others, of course. Oh, yeah. I've been doing that for a long while. It's my 23rd year|||在大学里，我只做 C++ 相关的事情。我想这是我们节目中第一次请到真正的老师。嗯，很高兴能成为第一个。我希望我不会是最后一个。当然还有其他人。哦，是的。我做这个已经很久了。今年是我从事这行的第 23 年……
doing that this year you know it's interesting i um i get asked a lot um these days by people for sort of like learning resources or how to get started with c++ or one question i get frequently it's like how do i learn like i want to get a job at nvidia how do i learn you know enough c plus plus to have the right skills for for y'all and i never know how to answer this question because i um i feel like i always learn very hands-on like i just immediately go to like experimenting and then you know exam completely example driven and so i never i i'm not somebody who learns well through like talks or books and what that, um, this is something that Connor and I have talked about in the past. Um, but I feel like,
doing that this year you know it's interesting i um i get asked a lot um these days by people for sort of like learning resources or how to get started with c++ or one question i get frequently it's like how do i learn like i want to get a job at nvidia how do i learn you know enough c plus plus to have the right skills for for y'all and i never know how to answer this question because i um i feel like i always learn very hands-on like i just immediately go to like experimenting and then you know exam completely example driven and so i never i i'm not somebody who learns well through like talks or books and what that, um, this is something that Connor and I have talked about in the past. Um, but I feel like,|||你知道这很有趣，我，嗯，现在经常有人向我询问学习资源，或者如何开始学习 C++，或者我经常遇到的一个问题是：“我该如何学习——我想去英伟达（NVIDIA）工作，我该如何学习足够的 C++，从而具备适合你们要求的技能？”我从来不知道该怎么回答这个问题，因为我，嗯，我觉得我总是通过非常动手的方式学习，比如我一上来就直接去尝试，然后，你知道的，完全是靠例子驱动的。所以我从来——我不是那种通过听演讲或看书能学得很好的人。这事儿，嗯，康纳和我在过去讨论过。嗯，但我觉得……
I feel like as somebody who's, who gets asked this question a lot and who is like sort of seen as, uh, you know, one of the leaders in the C++ community, I should have a better answer to this. So maybe you can help me develop a better answer for like, like when people want learning resources, where should I point them? I actually have a good suggestion there. And I would say, and then this is actually resonates personally for me, because I think around 2018, I went to a conference and I attended a workshop and I, at the time I was kind of had C++ 11 knowledge, but nothing, you know, really more than that. And I went to a workshop at a conference and I kind of learned a little bit about C++17 and kind of brushed up some skills there. So I think
I feel like as somebody who's, who gets asked this question a lot and who is like sort of seen as, uh, you" know, one of the leaders in the C++ community, I should have a better answer to this. So maybe you can help me develop a better answer for like, like when people want learning resources, where should I point them? I actually have a good suggestion there. And I would say, and then this is actually resonates personally for me, because I think around 2018, I went to a conference and I attended a workshop and I, at the time I was kind of had C++ 11 knowledge, but nothing, you know, really more than that. And I went to a workshop at a conference and I kind of learned a little bit about C++17 and kind of brushed up some skills there. So I think|||我觉得作为一个经常被问到这个问题、并且被视为，嗯，你知道的，C++ 社区领袖之一的人，我应该对此有一个更好的回答。所以也许你可以帮我构思一个更好的回答，比如当人们想要学习资源时，我应该把他们指引到哪里去？我其实有一个很好的建议。我想说——这实际上在个人层面上与我产生了共鸣，因为我认为大约在 2018 年，我去参加了一个会议，参加了一个工作坊。当时我掌握了一些 C++ 11 的知识，但除此之外，你知道的，真的没有更多了。我去参加了会议上的一个工作坊，了解了一点关于 C++17 的知识，并在那里温习了一些技能。所以我觉得……
I think that kind of segues into one of the reasons we have Patrice on this call. Oh, that's really sweet. I don't think it's a matter of amount of C++. You put that in terms of quantity, but it's a very big language. You can actually focus on some things. I think you can learn about programming with C++ without problem. Connor and I have discussed that in the past.
I think that kind of segues into one of the reasons we have Patrice on this call. Oh, that's really sweet. I don't think it's a matter of amount of C++. You put that in terms of quantity, but it's a very big language. You can actually focus on some things. I think you can learn about programming with C++ without problem. Connor and I have discussed that in the past.|||我觉得这正好引出了我们邀请帕特里斯参加这次通话的原因之一。哦，这太贴心了。我不认为这是一个 C++ 多少的问题。你是从数量的角度来看的，但这是一门非常庞大的语言。你实际上可以专注于某些事情。我认为你完全可以毫无问题地通过 C++ 学习编程。康纳和我在过去讨论过这一点。
You don't have to show anything complicated to get people started. And it's the kind of language that you can grow from and grow through and learn the things that you need along the way and get better at over time. But you can start very nicely with C++. If they want to do
You don't have to show anything complicated to get people started. And it's the kind of language that you can grow from and grow through and learn the things that you need along the way and get better at over time. But you can start very nicely with C++. If they want to do|||你不需要展示任何复杂的东西就能引导人们入门。而且这是一种你可以随之成长、并通过它不断成长，在沿途学习所需之物并随时间推移变得更好的语言。但你完全可以从 C++ 开始得非常好。如果他们想做……
something like what you do with NVIDIA, they will probably need to get a bit lower level from time to time. But they don't need to learn that right away. They can let it grow through them. It will work. Patrice, you mentioned that you teach most of the time in French, but you are going to be giving a class in English at CPP North. Do you want to tell us about that?
something like what you do with NVIDIA, they will probably need to get a bit lower level from time to time. But they don't need to learn that right away. They can let it grow through them. It will work. Patrice, you mentioned that you teach most of the time in French, but you are going to be giving a class in English at CPP North. Do you want to tell us about that?|||像你在英伟达所做的那样的事情，他们可能需要不时地深入到底层一点。但他们不需要立刻就去学那些。他们可以让这些知识随着自身成长而自然掌握。这行得通的。帕特里斯，你提到你大部分时间都是用法语教学，但你将在 CPP North 上用英语授课。你想给我们讲讲这个吗？
I will. I've done that quite a few times in the past, too. So, when your colleague Jason Mike contacted me saying, hey, we need a class there, do you have something to recommend or suggest? I went through a pile of things I had written as class proposals in the past. Now, the thing is, when COVID struck, there were training budgets here where I live. I said, well, prepare classes and we'll train people while they can go to work. And I had written a number of offerings like that. Some of them got used, some not.
I will. I've done that quite a few times in the past, too. So, when your colleague Jason Mike contacted me saying, hey, we need a class there, do you have something to recommend or suggest? I went through a pile of things I had written as class proposals in the past. Now, the thing is, when COVID struck, there were training budgets here where I live. I said, well, prepare classes and we'll train people while they can go to work. And I had written a number of offerings like that. Some of them got used, some not.|||好的。我过去也这么做好多次了。所以，当你的同事杰森和迈克联系我，说“嘿，我们需要那边有一门课，你有什么推荐或建议吗”时，我翻阅了一堆过去写过的课程提案。事情是这样的，当新冠疫情爆发时，我住的地方有培训预算。我说，好吧，准备一些课程，我们在人们可以上班的同时对他们进行培训。我当时写了许多这样的课程方案。其中一些被采纳了，一些没有。
And one of them was a generic introduction to generic programming thing over many languages, not just C++. And people hooked to that and said, oh, that sounds interesting. I'd do that, but just in C++ and please go deep. So I wrote something like that. It was quite a lot of fun, really.
And one of them was a generic introduction to generic programming thing over many languages, not just C++. And people hooked to that and said, oh, that sounds interesting. I'd do that, but just in C++ and please go deep. So I wrote something like that. It was quite a lot of fun, really.|||其中有一个是关于泛型编程的通用介绍，涉及多种语言，不仅仅是 C++。人们对这个很感兴趣，说：“哦，听起来很有趣。我想学那个，不过只要用 C++，而且请讲得深入一点。”所以我写了这样一门课。说实话，这真的挺有意思的。
I gave the class already once in French. We had a lot of pleasure. From the ground up, we start, you've maybe done macros and nothing else, and then you move way up to concepts and then pretty stuff going through traits and template parameters and stuff.
I gave the class already once in French. We had a lot of pleasure. From the ground up, we start, you've maybe done macros and nothing else, and then you move way up to concepts and then pretty stuff going through traits and template parameters and stuff.|||我已经用法语讲过一次这门课了。我们过得很愉快。我们从零开始，你可能只用过宏而别的什么都没用过，然后一路向上进阶到概念（concepts），再通过类型特征（traits）、模板参数等学习那些酷炫的内容。
It was very well received. When I suggested that for CVP North, they said, well, yeah, but put more concepts because concepts are cool. So I said, well, concepts are cool indeed. So it's a generic programming class from the ground up. You start presuming that you know almost nothing and
It was very well received. When I suggested that for CVP North, they said, well, yeah, but put more concepts because concepts are cool. So I said, well, concepts are cool indeed. So it's a generic programming class from the ground up. You start presuming that you know almost nothing and|||这门课反响很好。当我向 CVP North 提议这门课时，他们说：“嗯，是的，不过多加点概念（concepts），因为概念很酷。”所以我说：“嗯，概念确实很酷。”所以这是一门从零开始的泛型编程课。你开始时假设自己几乎什么都不会……
well, you're not expert at the end because you need practice. But we go through stuff, look at lots of examples, try to make people understand what's important, why it's important, how it works. Debug yourself and you get your messages like RenewTemplates can provide you.
well, you're not expert at the end because you need practice. But we go through stuff, look at lots of examples, try to make people understand what's important, why it's important, how it works. Debug yourself and you get your messages like RenewTemplates can provide you.|||嗯，学完之后你还不是专家，因为你需要练习。但我们会讲解各种内容，看大量的例子，努力让人们明白什么是重要的、为什么重要、它是如何工作的。学会自己调试，并看懂诸如重置模板（RenewTemplates，译者注：此处可能为口误或专有名词）能为你提供的那些错误信息。
And yeah, make it something enjoyable for everyone so that when you get out of the class, you know what you're talking about. I think you have the best title too. You forgot to mention the actual title of it is Generic Programming from Strange to Normal. That's the intent. It looks weird when you start and in the end, well, and the actual title of it is Generic Programming from Strange to Normal.
And yeah, make it something enjoyable for everyone so that when you get out of the class, you know what you're talking about. I think you have the best title too. You forgot to mention the actual title of it is Generic Programming from Strange to Normal. That's the intent. It looks weird when you start, and in the end, well, and the actual title of it is Generic Programming from Strange to Normal.|||是的，让这门课对每个人来说都充满乐趣，这样当你下课离开时，你就知道自己在谈论什么了。我觉得你的名字也起得最好。你忘了提它的实际标题是《泛型编程：从陌生到正常》（Generic Programming from Strange to Normal）。这就是初衷。一开始看起来很怪异，到最后，嗯，它的实际标题就是《泛型编程：从陌生到正常》。
That's the intent. It looks weird when you start, and in the end, well, it's like, well, I could do that for a living, and I'd be happy to do that. So that's, you know. I like people to get out of class and be happy about what they got. So I want them to maybe not feel they're proficient because 15 hours, it's not enough, but want to do more, enjoy yourself, know that you got the basics right,
That's the intent. It looks weird when you start, and in the end, well, it's like, well, I could do that for a living, and I'd be happy to do that. So that's, you know. I like people to get out of class and be happy about what they got. So I want them to maybe not feel they're proficient because 15 hours, it's not enough, but want to do more, enjoy yourself, know that you got the basics right,|||这就是初衷。一开始看起来很怪异，到最后，嗯，感觉就像是：“嗯，我可以靠这个维生，而且我会乐意这么做。”所以这就是，你知道的。我喜欢人们下课后为自己的收获感到高兴。所以我希望他们可能不会觉得自己已经精通了，因为 15 小时是不够的，但会想要做更多、享受其中、知道自己掌握了正确的基石……
and that you can actually solve problems yourself. So yeah, I think we're going to have a great time. That sounds like a really interesting course too, because there's going to be something for everyone, right? If you haven't done any sort of generic programming, you can still come and you're going to be starting from the ground up. But also, if you're with some familiarity, whatever level that is, C++11 sort of template metaprogramming or even you've started to dabble in c++ 20 it still sounds like uh folks that are interested are going to be able to come away
and that you can actually solve problems yourself. So yeah, I think we're going to have a great time. That sounds like a really interesting course too, geographically—oh wait, because there's going to be something for everyone, right? If you haven't done any sort of generic programming, you can still come and you're going to be starting from the ground up. But also, if you're with some familiarity, whatever level that is, C++11 sort of template metaprogramming or even you've started to dabble in c++ 20 it still sounds like uh folks that are interested are going to be able to come away|||并且你实际上能够自己解决问题。所以，是的，我觉得我们会度过一段非常棒的时光。听起来这也是一门非常有趣的课程，地理上——哦等等，因为每个人都能有所收获，对吧？如果你没做过任何形式的泛型编程，你依然可以来，而且你将从零开始。但同时，如果你已经有了一定程度的熟悉度——无论是什么水平，比如 C++11 风格的模板元编程，甚至你已经开始涉足 C++20——听起来感兴趣的人依然能够……
with having learned something at you know and it's sort of like depending on where you're at your learning curve uh you might find different parts of the course sort of oh that's the stuff that really clicks um which is which is kind, that's the stuff that really clicks, which is kind of, that's a kind of interesting model versus like some courses are just, you know, everything in C++20 and they don't do a lot of depth. They just do a lot of breadth. And if you try and cover that, like some of those courses are really, really good,
with having learned something at you know and it's sort of like depending on where you're at your learning curve uh you might find different parts of the course sort of oh that's the stuff that really clicks um which is which is kind, that's the stuff that really clicks, which is kind of, that's a kind of interesting model versus like some courses are just, you0 know, everything in C++20 and they don't do a lot of depth. They just do a lot of breadth. And if you try and cover that, like some of those courses are really, really good,|||学到一些东西，你知道的，这有点像根据你所处的学习曲线的位置，嗯，你可能会发现课程的不同部分让你觉得：“哦，这正是我真正豁然开朗的地方。”嗯，这——这有点，这正是我真正豁然开朗的地方，这有点，这是一种有趣的模式，相比之下，有些课程只是，你知道的，把 C++20 的所有东西都讲了一遍，但深度不够。它们只是追求广度。如果你试图涵盖这些内容，有些那样的课程其实非常非常好……
but you definitely aren't going to come away with the same kind of depth as compared to a course where you sort of just focus on one thing and go through that in detail. Yeah, but I think you need both kind of classes though so sometimes well the game people that i work with they pick from time to time the games people sometimes what they want to do is they're in between two projects and they want to know where the language is at right now so they want to you know the whole breadth of things and then they pick from that what they really need and they at least know about the rest, and that's totally fine.
但你绝对无法获得那种专注于单一事物并深入探讨的课程所带来的深度。是的，但我认为这两种课你都需要，有时候——我合作的游戏开发者们，他们不时会进行选择，游戏开发者有时想做的是，他们正处于两个项目之间，想了解目前语言的发展状况，所以他们希望了解整个广度的内容，然后从中挑选出他们真正需要的部分，至少对其他部分也有所了解，这完全没问题。
Now, this class is more for our learning thing. So as you said, it's more of an in-depth thing. We must not forget that some people are stuck with C++11, C++14 in their day jobs, while people working at Unreal, they have limitations right now, and other tools too. So there are tricks that don't work with older compilers. There are tricks that do work with older compilers. There are tricks that do work with older compilers. So going from the ground up,
现在，这门课更多是针对我们的学习任务。正如你所说，它更偏向于深度探讨。我们必须记住，有些人日常工作还在使用 C++11、C++14，而虚幻引擎的开发者目前也受到限制，其他工具也是如此。因此，有些技巧在旧编译器上无法使用，有些技巧则可以在旧编译器上使用。所以，从基础开始，
you can get ways to solve problems that are maybe sometimes not the most modern, even though we will see them, but that might help you in your day job because you're limited to tools that are six years back or something. So we'll try to make sure we cover everything there. Well, everything.
你可以找到解决问题的方法，这些方法可能有时不是最现代的（尽管我们也会讲到），但它们可能会对你的日常工作有所帮助，因为你受限于落后六年的工具。因此，我们会确保涵盖所有这些内容。嗯，所有内容。
Sufficient material to get you working and efficient regardless of the original compiler you're using. I mean, we've talked about a couple topics before Patrice showed up, but we were talking about biking, trips between New York and Toronto. We talked about kittens. We talked about helicopter, military flight simulations. I don't even think we've mentioned exactly when CPP North is happening. Well, of course we did. We said it was before my birthday. Oh, yeah. But did we say when your birthday is?
有足够的材料让你能够工作并保持高效，无论你使用的是哪个原始编译器。我是说，在帕特里斯（Patrice）出现之前，我们聊过一些话题，但我们当时在聊骑自行车，纽约和多伦多之间的旅行。我们聊了小猫。我们聊了直升机、军事飞行模拟。我甚至不觉得我们提到了 CPP North 具体是什么时候举办的。好吧，我们当然提到了。我们说它在我生日前。哦，对了。但我们说你的生日是什么时候了吗？
Yes, we said that my birthday was July 21st. Oh, yeah. So maybe that's what now CPP North, unfortunately, to the ADSP listeners are going to know CPP North as. It's the three days preceding bryce's birthday and the two days preceding that is the workshops that we have yeah i wanted to say a couple more things about the conference before we wrapped up here so one um i you know i want to acknowledge our program chair first of all right he's got a it's not an easy job um so connor like i think has lined up a great program
是的，我们说过我的生日是 7 月 21 日。哦，对了。所以这也许就是现在 ADSP 的听众们所知道的 CPP North。它是布莱斯（Bryce）生日前的前三天，而在此之前两天是我们举办的研讨会。是的，在我们在讨论结束前，我还想多说几点关于会议的事情。首先，我想感谢我们的节目主席，对吧？他担任这个职位可不容易，所以康纳（Connor）组织了一场非常棒的节目，我认为
we will be releasing the program here in the next couple days by the time this podcast goes out the program some version of a tentative program should probably be online one or two days after it so probably by the time the listener is listening to this, it'll be available in the internet. Yeah. And we have some keynote speakers, great keynote speakers lined up, Sean Parent, Kate Gregory, Titus Winters. I think, you know, for a first time program chair, those are amazing keynote speakers to have lined up.
我们将在接下来的几天内发布节目日程。当这个播客发布时，某个版本的暂定日程应该会在一两天后上线，所以当听众听到这个节目时，它应该已经在互联网上发布了。是的。我们还有一些主题演讲嘉宾，非常棒的主题演讲嘉宾，肖恩·帕ent（Sean Parent）、凯特·格雷戈里（Kate Gregory）、提图斯·温特斯（Titus Winters）。我认为，对于一个首次担任节目主席的人来说，能邀请到这些主题演讲嘉宾真是太棒了。
So it should be a great conference. And then the last note I wanted to kind of leave here is because we're, we are releasing the program here just probably simultaneously with the, the podcast is that we know it's probably maybe a little late for people to get access to the early bird. So we are providing a special code that you can enter on registration to get the early bird rate up until April 30th. So that'll be ADSP CPP North that you can do on registration. Look at that. I didn't even know about that. And
所以这应该是一个非常棒的会议。然后我想留下的最后一点是，因为我们发布节目日程的时间可能与播客发布的时间差不多，我们知道大家要获取早鸟票可能已经有点晚了。因此，我们提供了一个特殊的代码，您可以在注册时输入该代码，以在 4 月 30 日之前获得早鸟价。注册时您可以输入 ADSP CPP North。你看，我甚至不知道这件事，而且
I probably should have known about that, but wow, look at that. Our listeners, the listener, is it plural or singular in this case? I don't even know. It's the listener. It's always the listener. The listener, but there's multiple singular listener. I can't do it. Has access to, yeah, a special code. It's our first ever. We've been hoping for a sponsorship from Bubbly and Lululemon. That hasn't come through yet.
我可能本该知道的，但哇，你看。我们的听众——听众，在这种情况下是复数还是单数？我甚至不知道。这就是听众。永远都是听众。听众，但有多个单数听众。我搞不懂了。可以获取到……是的，一个特殊的代码。这是我们的第一次。我们一直希望能获得 Bubbly 和 Lululemon 的赞助。这还没落实。
But in the meantime, you can get a discount with a special code. ADSP, CPP North. And on top of Patrice. So Patrice is giving a full day workshop. Or is it a full day, two day, full two day workshop. There's I think two other workshops as well. One's Guy Davidson, I think. Guy Davidson is giving something on game programming, isn't he? Yeah, Guy Davidson and Stephanie Brenham.
但与此同时，您可以使用特殊代码获得折扣。ADSP，CPP North。除此之外，帕特里斯还要讲课。帕特里斯将举办一个全天的工作坊。还是整整一整天、两天、整整两天的工坊？我想还有另外两个工作坊。一个是盖伊·戴维森（Guy Davidson），我想。盖伊·戴维森不是要讲游戏编程吗？是的，盖伊·戴维森和斯蒂芬妮·布伦纳姆（Stephanie Brenham）。
They're tied to being on a game development with low latency and high excellence is the title of their talk. It'll be the first time this workshop will be given at our conference. And then Rainier Grimm will be doing a concurrency, one with Modern C++. Good classes too.
他们演讲的题目是“致力于低延迟和高卓越性的游戏开发”。这将是该工作坊首次在我们的会议上举办。然后雷纳·格里姆（Rainier Grimm）将用现代 C++ 主讲并发编程。也是非常不错的课程。
Yeah, so I think, and I think so I'm not sure how many people are going to do this, but I know Bryce, you've already booked your sort of travel. And so I think you're coming like the week and before and saving to the weekend. So yeah, it's my typical,
是的，所以我想——我不确定有多少人会这样做，但我知道布莱斯，你已经订好了你的行程。所以我想你会在周末前一周来，一直待到周末。所以，是的，这是我的典型，
my typical way of operating. So, yeah, I think for people that are considering coming, like that's a, a really nice option because the conference plus the workshops would be from Saturday till Wednesday. And then you could still have, you know, Thursday, Friday to check out, you know, the city. Because, I mean, if you're in Canada, people from Vancouver will say that like, oh, Vancouver is the most beautiful city in Canada,
我典型的工作方式。所以，是的，我认为对于考虑前来的人来说，这是一个非常不错的选择，因为会议加上工作坊将从周六一直持续到周三。然后你仍然可以在周四、周五去逛逛这座城市。因为，如果你在加拿大，温哥华的人会说，哦，温哥华是加拿大最美丽的城市，
blah, blah, blah. It is very beautiful. I've lived there. I studied there, but like, I think Toronto and also Montreal, Montreal is a blast. They've got amazing food. One of the, like, this is a small tangent on Montreal, but Montreal has something that no other Canadian city has that I've been to, which is this sort of eatery district where it sort of feels like new Orleans a little bit where like there's two or three floors to every restaurant with balconies that wrap around. And all four corners of an intersection will have that exact same style. So you can be sitting at the corner of an intersection on the third floor, and you'll be 10 meters away from someone at a different restaurant at the same floor level, and you can wave to them and say hi.
巴拉巴拉。它确实很美丽。我在那住过。我在那上过学，但是，我认为多伦多还有蒙特利尔，蒙特利尔太棒了。他们有令人惊叹的美食。其中之一，这是一个关于蒙特利尔的小插曲，蒙特利尔拥有其他我曾去过的加拿大城市所没有的东西，那就是这种餐饮区，有点像新奥尔良，每家餐厅都有两到三层楼，带有环绕式阳台。一个十字路口的四个角落都有完全相同的风格。所以你可以坐在十字路口转角的第三层楼，距离另一家餐厅同一楼层的人只有 10 米远，你可以向他们挥手打招呼。
Whereas Toronto doesn't have that. So potentially what you want to do is come to cpp north and then take a train over to to montreal because it's only a four or five hour train ride is that what we're gonna do connor you're gonna take me to montreal for my birthday oh no i just do you're you've mentioned food so of course we're leaving out what I suspect to be the most important event of C++ North, which is I assume that the Canadians are preparing some sort of blind bagel test tasting in which I will be forced to admit the supremacy of the Montreal bagel. Well, we would have to move the bagels from Montreal to Toronto. You want them fresh. A later CP North event,
而多伦多没有那样的风景。所以你可能想做的是来参加 cpp north，然后坐火车去蒙特利尔，因为那只需要四五个小时的火车车程。这就是我们要做的吗，康纳？你要带我去蒙特利尔过生日吗？哦，不，我只是……你提到了食物，所以我们当然漏掉了我猜想是 C++ North 最重要的活动，我假设加拿大人正在准备某种盲测贝果（百吉饼）品尝活动，我将被迫承认蒙特利尔百吉饼的至高地位。好吧，我们得把百吉饼从蒙特利尔运到多伦多。你希望它们是新鲜的。未来的 CP North 活动，
which will hold Montreal at some point, we'll try to alternate. Or, again, just Connor. Forget moving the bagels to Connor and I. We'll move Connor and I to the bagels. There's a great bagel place. There's a couple great bagel places in Toronto. I'll bring a
我们会在某个时候把活动办到蒙特利尔，我们会试着轮流举办。或者，干脆别管把百吉饼运给康纳和我了。我们把康纳和我运到百吉饼那去。那里有一家很棒的百吉饼店。多伦多有几家很棒的百吉饼店。我会带一个
test sample to patrice and he can confirm whether or not they uh they they meet the standard with montreal bagel and then we can we can then grace uh rice with the uh the taste as well that sounds quite reasonable to me i don't i don't want to start a war i mean there's already a war but like um i had there's a new i don't actually remember the name of the place but there's a montreal bagel place that just opened in toronto and they had these very small the holes were very large in them i was a bit confused on why there was not more bagel and i i gotta be honest i was like i took a bite and was my first thought was this is not as good as the bagels I had in New York. I swear I did not pay Connor anything for that.
测试样本给帕特里斯，他可以确认它们是否符合蒙特利尔百吉饼的标准，然后我们就可以把这个味道带给布莱斯了。听起来对我挺合理的。我不想挑起战争，我是说已经有战争了，但是，我有一家新的——我其实记不清店名了，但多伦多刚开了一家蒙特利尔百吉饼店，他们做得很小，中间的洞非常大。我有点困惑为什么百吉饼没有更多分量，说实话，我咬了一口，我的第一反应是这没有我在纽约吃的百吉饼好吃。我发誓我没有付给康纳任何钱让他这么说。
Even in Montreal, there's two kinds of schools. There's a Fairmount bagels and the San Diego bagels. And they don't agree on which one's which, which one's the best or something. So bagels are a fighting issue all over the place. It sounds like we are going to have to make a trip to Montreal then, Bryce. This is the only way to settle this. We do have the conference in Toronto, so let's fix that first. I'm going to say like the hotel,
即使在蒙特利尔，也有两派。有 Fairmount 百吉饼和 St-Viateur 百吉饼。他们对于哪家才是最好的争论不休。所以百吉饼到处都是个争论不休的话题。听起来我们不得不去一趟蒙特利尔了，布莱斯。这是解决这个问题的唯一方法。我们在多伦多有会议，所以让我们先把这个搞定。我要说的是酒店，
you can basically walk out of the hotel and be at the train station. That's true. That's true. we are right at basically at union which is where the trains to montreal start so all right with that um this episode it was an interesting journey yeah it was a blast i'm but yeah thanks both uh patrice and jason for coming on um i mean i'll be seeing jason virtually over the next couple months but i'll be seeing both of you and bryce i guess probably actually the next time I see all three of you almost definitely in person at the same time we'll be at CPP North. So yeah. Awesome. Well, thank you. Yeah. Thank you. Bye. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你基本上可以走出酒店就是火车站。确实如此。确实如此。我们基本上就在联合车站旁边，开往蒙特利尔的火车就是从那里出发的。好的，那么，这一期节目是一次有趣的旅程。是的，太棒了。不过，谢谢帕特里斯和杰森两位的到来——我的意思是，在接下来的几个月里我会在虚拟世界见到杰森，但我会见到你们俩，还有布莱斯，我猜下次我见到你们三个人的时候，几乎肯定是在线下同一时间，那就是在 CPP North。所以，是的。太棒了。好吧，谢谢。再见。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝你们有美好的一天。这一期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。